[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar iterative genome engineering for
rapid improvement of protein activity
and production
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes and brought to
you by inscripta to learn more visit
inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
eric abate director analytical
biochemistry applications development in
scripta
eric you may now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction
so today i'm going to give you an
introduction to enscripta's onyx
platform and tell you about the
iterative genome engineering workflow on
that platform
then i'm going to tell you about a few
applications where we use this iterative
genome editing in order to improve the
function of a protein as well as the
expression of a heterologously expressed
protein in yeast
so there are a lot of challenges in the
synthetic biology and the biological
engineering space so
looking at something like forward
engineering where you're trying to
produce more of a product or produce it
faster
like heterologous protein production it
really requires high dimensional
optimization and unfortunately we don't
really know the rules of biology that
allow us to go in and tinker with the
genome in order to optimize the
expression of a protein or a small
molecule
in the reverse direction when you're
doing
genome discovery
you're really trying to understand how
the system works and you want to
generate some basic knowledge about that
system so you need tools that allow you
to take that system apart in order to
re-engineer it
for a particular purpose or phenotype
that you're looking for
so in order to fulfill the promises of
synthetic biology we really need high
throughput tools to make diverse edits
genome-wide
so if you look at a lot of the current
tools that are available in the genome
editing space there's a lot of
challenges
so very often they lack precision
there are slow and laborious workflows
there's a lack of diverse edit types
mostly loss of function mutations are
being introduced
and it's difficult to separate
hitchhiker mutations
from true causal mutations and this is a
classic problem
for something like classical mutagenesis
another problem is when you look at all
these different technologies that are
out there
you either have to sacrifice the number
of genomic locations that you can target
or the variety of edit types that you
can introduce at those genomic locations
and what you really want to do in order
to do true genome engineering or genome
discovery is get up here into this
quadrant where you're able to introduce
a lot of variety of edit types at many
different genomic locations
so towards that end i'd like to
introduce you to enscriptazonics
platform which allows for programmable
and trackable variation to be introduced
into a genome
and currently we support e coli and
yeast
okay so the platform is truly a platform
it has a lot of different components to
it and it supports all aspects of the
design generate test learn cycle which
is kind of fundamental
to
science the scientific method
so it all starts with the encrypted
designer excuse me software
which allows you to go in and basically
design the edits that you want to
introduce into the genome you don't have
to know anything about guide rnas or
design scores the software basically
takes care of all of that
after you finish designing your library
which can have up to thousands of
different edits
that initiates the manufacturing of the
reagents and the consumables that are
necessary in order to build that library
in a matter of weeks you will receive
those
consumables which then goes into the
second component of the platform which
is the onyx instrument itself
if you put the consumables in along with
the cells that you want to build this
library in and you press go and in a
matter of two to four days depending on
if you're doing e coli or yeast you'll
get this tube of engineered cells that
comes out of it
so this two of cells um contains
basically thousands of different strains
that were designed within uh the
platform and each cell will contain at
most one of the edits that was contained
contained in your design library but
it's a population of all of those edits
within within one
tube of cells
then this will go into the test aspect
which is
this is what the customer supplies
either if you're going to do some sort
of screening workflow or a selection
type of workflow
after you identify your hits from
screening or have enriched for your
population through a selection you
submit that for dna sequencing that dna
sequencing data then gets imported into
another package called resolver and this
is what allows you to link the genotype
of
the edit
with the the phenotype that you've
obtained
from this you'll you'll generate some
information that will allow you to go
through this
cycle once again so not only does the
platform allow you to
go through each aspect of the cycle but
i hope to convince you um with the
applications i'm going to talk about
later that you can go through this quite
rapidly
so the platform has optimized designs it
utilizes the proprietary mad seven
nuclease
push buttons simple workflows anywhere
from 100 to 10 000 designs per library
there's a single edit per cell you can
introduce diverse edit types which i'll
talk about in a moment anywhere from 1
to 63 base pairs
also there is a dna barcode that's
attached to each edit or associated with
each edit so you can do rapid genotyping
through just sequencing the barcode
and it really democratizes genome
editing basically bringing genome
editing to the masses
so there's a wide diversity of edit
types that you can introduce and this
can target both the non-coding region
say regulatory regions
promoters
terminators of genes
as well as the coding region itself so
we like to very often
introduce knockout or produce knockout
libraries where we introduce a triple
stop
codon towards the five prime end of a
gene or you can even do saturation
mutagenesis mutating one residue to all
their possible residues within a protein
so lots of different types of edits you
can introduce
okay so some of the specs so we
currently support e coli and s or vca
this includes inscriptive standard
strains as well as related customer
strains
again you can target the coding and
non-coding regions in the native genome
or if you've introduced a heterologous
sequence as you'll see in the
applications i'm going to talk about you
can also target that as well
uh designs per library for e coli it's
one two sorry hundred to ten thousand or
cervica a hundred to six thousand edits
per design
one edit per cell you can do insertions
deletions and substitutions anywhere
from one to sixty three base pairs
the library composition that comes out
of the instrument it's typically uh
greater than 90 of the designs within
your design library are contained within
that population
and the editing fraction is anywhere
from 15 to 75 percent depending on the
the complexity of the edits that you're
trying to introduce
as far as time radiant delivery is
approximately three weeks and the
library build is anywhere from two to
four days depending upon
whether it's e coli or yeast
however the hands-on time with the
actual instrument is less than an hour
okay
so that's an introduction to the
platform now i want to tell you about
the iterative genome engineering
workflow that has been recently released
for the platform
so this is what the workflow looks like
so you build your first library you take
it through your screening workflow here
and you identify your top hits
you take one of those hits
and you want to carry that into the
second round so in order to do that you
either you'll need to cure the plasmid
or plasmids that are contained within
that strain that was necessary in order
to introduce the edits
and for e coli which has two plasmids it
requires an active curing process and
inscripta provides a kit
a non-instrument kit that allows you to
to do that curing process
for essay or vca it's a passive process
so once you've cured your plasmid that
can go immediately into round two
where you
build another library on top of that
strain basically adding a second round
of edits
going through
your phenotyping workflow identify your
top hits and then go through the process
again of during the plasmids and
building your library so it's a very
simple workflow in order to do this
okay so now i want to tell you about
some applications where we use this
iterative genome engineering
for a particular purpose so this first
one is where we wanted to do
heterologous protein engineering so
basically do some protein engineering on
a protein that we've introduced into the
genome
of e coli in this example
so in this example we used
a classic gfp protein
which is a nice model system to use
we integrated into the host genome with
a strong promoter this is an igem j23102
promoter a strong rhymosome binding site
and a t0 terminator
so once you've introduced your
heterologous protein there's lots of
different ways
you can
design libraries to introduce diversity
into that protein so you can do snips
you can do insertions you can do
deletions you can target the regulatory
region or use regulatory data you can
use evolutionary and strain variants any
published enzyme or protein variants or
you can do structural guided variants
so in this particular case
what was done was
utilize a database of fluorescence
variants of gfp so basically the super
folder gfp sequence was aligned against
the published database and hot spots
were identified
within
the coding sequence and basically a
hotspot was defined as any place that
had great greater than um one mutation
at a particular location
so once those hotspots were identified a
saturation mutagenesis library was built
targeting those hot spots and in total
there were 723 edits within that library
and basically those edits were agnostic
to the mutation effect from the database
so after that library was built in e
coli
and you can see here's an example of of
some of the
fluorescent colonies that were obtained
after the library building in total 198
i'm sorry 192 colonies um were screened
through this workflow they were tested
at three different excitation and
emission pairs
using either yfp
gfp or bfp
excitation and emission wavelengths
so here's a look at some of the data
in the gfp versus yfp
signal
so you can see there's lots of them that
still have the wild type uh gfp signal
there are many of them that were
disrupted for fluorescence so those were
not tolerated mutations so that's not
surprising
there was one hit that seemed to have a
significant improvements in fluorescence
signal in the gfp
axis
and then there's also a yfp variant that
was also identified
if you look at three axes now
gfp bfp and yfp this is that improved
intensity one that i mentioned we also
saw lots of bfp variants or bfp shifted
variants
and one of those variants was a
previously identified well characterized
a tyrosine 66 to histidine variant so
you can identify
variants that that was already known in
the literature
this improved
intensity variant was a phenylalanine
145 to methionine variant and that was
carried through with a second round of
iterative editing
so basically this variant then had that
same initial library built on top of it
and then 96 additional
samples were screened
and what was found here was uh that
there is two isolates showed a high
yellow shift one of them had a very high
intensity here and this happened to be a
novel yfp variant that hadn't previously
been characterized
so this is just an example of using gfp
as sort of a model protein obviously you
can substitute your favorite protein or
any enzyme in its place but just to show
you an example that you can do iterative
rounds
of genome engineering
within the onyx platform in order to
identify improved variants
okay now i want to tell you about
another application where we wanted to
improve the heterologous expression of a
protein in yeast
using this rapid iterative genome
engineering
so protein approach is pushing
production is important for the
bioeconomy and it's important for say
industrial biotechnology where you want
to produce biofuels or use enzymes and
textiles or food production or
processing
obviously in biopharma or therapeutics
you can target metabolic disorders like
diabetes which is a big one with insulin
or in cancer therapies
and a really hot area right now is this
alternative protein market where you
want a non-animal source of say meat
protein or dairy proteins or egg
proteins
and really the current tools to improve
protein production
are quite limited
so you can
you know one common technique is to
insert extra copies of a gene within the
genome so this can definitely improve
expression but those improvements tend
to plateau
you can
tinker around with the expression
cassette so you can target the promoter
or use alternate promoters
different terminators
you can change the gene design you know
codon usage or codon optimization or if
your protein is secreted you can try
different signal sequences
and a very common way that currently
used is doing um classical immunogenesis
of a production strain
so
this allows you to basically take your
production strain treat it with some
sort of mutagen this induces introduces
tens to hundreds of different snips
throughout the genome
it can introduce beneficial mutation as
well as deleterious mutations
simultaneously so that's a problem
it can be complicated to identify causal
mutations
for the improved production
or the improved phenotype you're looking
for
so what we think is that the onyx
platform
provides a really attractive alternative
to improving protein production
so we wanted to come up with an
application to test this out
and we decided to use um our model
enzyme is an enzyme called cbh1 so this
is a cellobiohydrolase one it's an
enzyme that's involved in cellulose
degradation
it has a lot of importance in this
consolidated bioprocessing
model which basically you would take a
strain that produces various enzymes
those enzymes would degrade a feedstock
which is very often waste plant material
when that waste plant material is
degraded it produces sugar those sugar
are then consumed by that same strain in
order to produce some sort of fuel or
some sort of chemical that's used for
some industrial process
so this is the model we wanted to use
so we utilized a fungal cbh1 that was
codon optimized for expression and yeast
and we used
the native fungal signal sequence so
this protein would be secreted
we
used the native yeast eno2 promoter to
drive expression of the cbh1 and a dit1
terminator so the base strain that was
used was a string called send pk and we
generated a single copy genomic
integration of this expression cassette
so the assay is pretty straightforward
we use this synthetic substrate called
pnp beta lactoprintocide
when cbh1 acts on it it releases
paranatural phenol which has a
characteristic absorbance at 405
nanometers so we could very quickly
measure the amount of active protein
that is being produced by measuring the
absorbance at 405 nanometers
and this base parent strain that was
used for expression had no detectable
activity
on the substrate
so to show you a little bit about the
noise within the assay all of the
screening workflow was done in a high
throughput format where we use 96 well
plates anywhere from about 10 to 20
plates of samples per library
so if i pick 96 colonies of this base
expression strain
take it through the workflow
you could see the the average and
standard deviation
of the measurements and a very low cv
which gave us pretty good confidence
that we could pull out hits even that
even if they had a very low improvement
in cbh1 expression
okay so these are the we wanted to test
a bunch of different library concepts
um
for trying to improve the production of
cbh1 so this is the first on library
strategy and it really focused on a lot
of different diversity
so we had genome-wide libraries so
basically targeting all over the genome
this included a genome-wide knockout
library so knocking out every gene in
yeast
a genome-wide synthetic terminator
insertion library so we utilized a
synthetic terminator
and inserted it at the three prime end
of every gene in yeast and this can have
an impact on the ultimate
expression of that gene
and then we had another library where we
basically introduced one to 59 base pair
deletions kind of throughout the genome
and these deletions can target either
the open reading frame itself of a gene
or the regulatory regions of that gene
so those are our sort of genome-wide
unbiased untargeted libraries as well as
the targeted libraries or rational
libraries we had two libraries that were
targeting the eno2 promoter that was
driving expression of cbh1
so we had one library concept where we
took the predicted transcription factor
binding sites and either inserted extra
copies of them or deleted them
another strategy where we took those
same binding sites and we swapped in
various other yeast transcription factor
binding sites
at those locations
we also had a cb cbh1 alternate codon
library so this is basically a site
saturation synonymous mutation library
where you take every at each position
you take um you mutate those uh codons
to all other possible codons that encode
for the same amino acids we're not
making um mutations
or you know we're not changing the the
amino acid we're just changing the codon
i also had another library that i'm
calling the targeted knockout library
and in this library basically mine the
literature looking for genes that have
been previously shown that when you
knock them out they improve the
production of a heterologous protein
i also did a genome-wide protease
deletion library so host proteases can
often be problematic for heterologically
expressed protein
and then i also targeted genes in the
glycosylation pathway
for deletion as well
because they can have an impact on
secretion of proteins
so these are the concepts that we tested
okay so to give you a feel for the size
of these libraries and the number of
isolate screen there were seven total
libraries um that were built about 15
000 different edits
designed within those libraries
and i screened about 8 500 isolates
i'm also showing the estimated library
coverage from these different concepts
so this is really based on lots of
different factors one of them is the
size of the library the number of
isolates that are screened obviously
the editing fraction within that library
because not all cells are going to be
edited
and also the distribution of edits
within that population because you're
not going to have an equal distribution
of all the edits within that population
so that's what's used to estimate the
amount of library coverage that was
screened screening these number of
isolates so you can see some of these
libraries some of the larger ones are
screened at fairly shallow diversity you
know four percent to 18
whereas some of the smaller libraries
like the targeted knockout library you
know you're screening a fair amount you
know two-thirds of the diversity that's
contained within that library
i'm showing the number of retest hits so
all of these libraries go through a
primary screen we take those hits we
identify they go through a retest in
quadruplicate so that we can confirm
that they're indeed hits and then also
get some statistics on those hits
and this is showing the number of unique
edits um from each one of these
different libraries so some of the the
smaller libraries where we do you know
fairly deep screening you can see that
where we're pulling out the same hits
multiple times or more often um we'll
pull out the same hits multiple times
whereas that's not true for some of the
the larger libraries
uh and in total from all of the
screening we identified 74
unique hits from this primary screen
and i think one of the important points
i want to bring up here is that even
though we have these very large
libraries and we're only screening you
know a fraction of the diversity that's
contained within those we're still able
to identify a significant number of
unique hits and ultimately this is the
important part of your first round
screening is diversity generation to
identify diversity that you can then
combine in subsequent rounds of genome
engineering and that's what we wanted to
do so shallow screening of large
libraries can be very effective at
identifying diversity that you can then
combine in subsequent rounds
okay
so here's what the data looks like this
is all retest data for all the hits that
we identified
and i'm showing the full change over the
base strain so the full change in cbh1
activity over the base stream
and i colored it by these different
library concepts so all seven different
library concepts so you can see that
with the genome-wide and the untargeted
basically untargeted or unbiased
approach we were able to identify a lot
of hits
and then from the targeted libraries as
well we were able to identify some nice
hits anywhere from about a 1.1 to a 1.6
fold increase in cbh1 activity
this is showing the average of the
quadruplicates as well as the standard
deviation
if we pull out a hit one time from the
library if we pull it out multiple times
then we averaged those hits and got the
standard deviation from those hits and
you can see that there's fairly
low noise
within the assay which gives us pretty
good confidence
in the fold improvement that we're
obtaining
okay so this is all the primary
screening
or the the first round of screening i
should say
so now you know we identified all this
diversity now we want to start to build
on that diversity and we decided to use
two different strategies
in doing that
so for the second round we wanted to do
a targeted type of library as well as an
untargeted type of library so again
that's what we did in our first round
right it's a biased or sorry an unbiased
approach an untargeted approach and then
a targeted type of approach or a
rational type of approach
so what we did is we took two
first-round hits
i wanted to see if there was any
difference and depending on which hits
we picked
and we built a genome-wide knockout
library the same genome-wide knockout we
used in our in our first round
after that we identified a top second
round hit
and then we built another library on top
of that and in this case we used the all
the first round hits we identified and
we stacked it on top of that second
round hit so that was one path
and we identified our third round hits
in another path we took a first round
hit the same one that we used up here
and we took the first round hits and
stacked them on top of that so it's
basically the hits on top of a hit
so those are the two strategies we used
okay
so here i'm showing the primary
screening data
from
the first round libraries the second
round libraries and the third round
libraries and this is showing the fold
improvement
in cbh1 expression over the base string
so the first round hits again all those
different library concepts that that we
identified
we took a top well we took actually two
hits from this first round and carried
it to the second round and the first
thing we did as i mentioned we built a
genome-wide knockout on top of them and
that's what's shown here so those are
those are these two things
and you can see that there's a slight
difference in um
basically the base strain performance
that we used but we got nice improvement
um from from these genomic knockouts
stacked on top of that
and it was what we pretty much um showed
is that the fold improvement over the
base drain so like going from here to
here is kind of similar from here to
here so
basically the full improvement didn't
really depend on which base strain that
we were picking and what we decided to
do to carry through the third round was
basically take let's take our top hit
into the third round
in this library here we took this same
hit
from the first round and we stacked a
all the first round hits on top of that
library and what you can see is we see
again a nice improvement
in cbh1 performance so stacking
libraries on top of hits from the first
round
caused an even greater improvement in
cbh1 expression
so we took this first round hit
and then we took
the all the first round hits and stacked
it or sorry this is the second round hit
and we stacked all the first run hits on
top of that and that's what's shown here
again showing that we see a nice
improvement um in overall cbh1
production
so through
iterative rounds of genome engineering
were able to gradually increase
and improve the expression of cbh1
okay
so now this is all the retest data from
the first round which i've already shown
you
the second round and now the third round
to kind of show you what does the retest
data you know look like
so these three different libraries from
the second round you can see that
there's a nice improvement
in cvh1 expression
and then we saw significant improvement
into the third round again
um showing the the standard deviation of
quadruplicate measurements or
if we pull out the same hit multiple
time we average those so you can see
there's very lice very low noise within
the screening workflow
in the high throughput the screen
strategy that we used
so overall these different rounds um
we're able to continue improving cbh1
expression
okay
so
we built a lot of libraries that were
basically targeting all over the genome
whether it be a genome-wide knockout
deletions across the genome genome-wide
terminator library or a targeted
knockout library
so
all of those libraries were basically
targeting lots of different places in
the genome
and we pulled out a lot of hits doing
this strategy and what i wanted to see
was was there any commonality between
the the genes that were targeted for
these different library strategies
and then
when i um kind of categorized them by
different cellular processes i saw you
know something interesting so
if we look at
protein degradation we identified a lot
of hits
that target genes in protein degradation
it's targeting protein trafficking
cellular stress response
transcription and translation processes
nuclear transport glycosylation pathway
some of them didn't really fit into any
of these i kind of lump them all
together into other
and also interestingly identified 11
hits from these strategies were were
genes of basically unknown function
now this was pretty exciting to us um
because using this sort of unbiased or
untargeted strategy you know allowed us
to pull out genes of unknown function
which you likely would not target
through some sort of rational
library building strategy
so identified all these hits in all
these different cellular processes and i
think what was kind of exciting to us
you know looking at these is hey you
know if i think about heterologous
protein production these are all the
pathways that i think might be important
for that you know you don't want to
degrade your protein that you're
expressing you need to make sure that
it's being trafficked you know in the
proper way through the secretion this is
probably
stressful to the cell in order to
overproduce a protein you need to
optimize transcription and translation
machinery nuclear transport so it was
exciting to us that you know these are
all processes that you might imagine to
be important for heterogeneous protein
production
and in total
um 69 unique genes were targeted for
edits
from these these hits that we identified
from these various different library
strategies
okay so that is all the high throughput
screening data
and we said okay that's great if you
look at what happens in in a shake sorry
in a
96 volt plate with 300 microliters of
media
you can identify these hits but what
happens when you scale it up
um
so what we want to do is at least scale
it up to you know shake flask cultures
so we decided to scale up
several of the hits to 25 mil shake
flash cultures using the same media
ypd
uh with glucose that was used for the
high throughput screening
and we identified or we picked three
different hits three different hit
strains from each round
so basically nine different hit strains
and then compared it to our base string
and that's what's shown here
so first i'm showing just the growth
curves so this is basically just looking
at um the absorbance of 600 nanometers
over time
so taking an early time point about six
hours 24 hours 48 hours and 72 hours
again three strains from the first round
three from the second round three from
the third round and then the bass drain
for comparison
at this is shown as this dashed uh black
line
and i think what was interesting and
immediately popped out at us is hey all
the hit strains we identified they
basically have decreased growth relative
to
this base strain that we were using
so this was interesting in two ways one
of them is
excuse me
that
we're seeing improved production of cbh1
and since we're not seeing greater
growth than the base strain it means
that this can't be explained by just
better growth of those strains in fact
they grow slightly worse than the base
strain
another interesting point is that
there's been reports in the literature
that very often strains that have
improved heterologous protein production
have decreased growth relative to say a
base strain of expression and this kind
of makes sense if you think about it
because
more amounts or greater amounts of the
carbon is being diverted towards protein
production instead of towards biomass
production
so our results kind of fit with what's
been reported in the literature and it's
interesting that all of our hits from
the different rounds basically grew
worse um
than the base stream
okay so that's growth now what we really
care about is what about cbh1 expression
in cbh1 production
so that's what's shown here
again the base strain is shown here as a
black
dotted line
and it was very nice for us to see that
our first round hits
clustered near each other with improved
production over this bass drain
the second round hits also showed
improved production over the first round
hits
and they clustered together nicely and
then
finally the third round
hits
at the highest level of production and
they clustered near each other
so there's this one variant here
which is one of the third round hits
which actually if we go back had kind of
delayed growth here um
looks like you also have delayed cbh1
expression up to about 24 hours then
when you get to 48 hours it pops right
up and has um much greater cbh1
expression relative to these other
strains that were tested
okay and then the top hit that we
identified basically had a four-fold
improvement um in cbh1 production over
the bass drain um
pretty much at the i think 24 48 and 72
hour time points it was about a four
full
improvement so significantly uh improved
cbh1 production over these three rounds
of genome engineering
work that we did
okay so this is showing you the data
right so this is the the types of
improvements that we were able to get
through these three rounds
now i want to talk to you about well
what's the time investment
involved in doing this and um the work
investment you know the fte requirement
in order to do this type of work so i
wanted to go through this uh basically
project timeline
uh so i broke it down it's different
steps so first you have to design the
libraries and manufacture the reagents
then you have to build the libraries on
the instrument you have to phenotype and
genotype
those libraries and the hits
so this takes about a month time
um then if you're doing iterative rounds
of genome engineering you'll have to
cure the plasmid
from the hit that you carry to the next
round
and then you can either design a new
library like we did with the cbh1 hits
on hit library so we had to take all
those hits design a new library and
manufacture reagents to build that
library or in the other strategy we used
a genome-wide knockout library so that
library we had designed we had multiple
kits of that particular library so we
were able to immediately go into the
second round if we use that
library that we already have and this
this is a strategy that you can use
designing new libraries as well as
recycling libraries
that you've used in the past
and then those will then obviously go
into your screening
workflow
okay so here's the project timeline
so the first round of screening work um
that we did
uh that took about three months so it
was about
three weeks to design and manufacture
the reagents
um it's about three to four days to
build the libraries
because this is using yeast
and then it's about a month time to
phenotype and then genotype
those different those seven different
libraries that were used in the first
round
and we could do you know the library
bills had to be done
in in series because you only had one
instrument but you could do the
phenotyping in parallel
okay so in total to identify those
74 unique hits from the first round it
took about three months
okay after doing that we picked a first
round hit you can take one of your first
round hits
and then you have to cure the plasmid
so the curing procedure takes about a
week in order to cure the plasmid and
then qc that strain in order to make
sure that indeed that plasmid has been
cured
because if the plasma is not cured
your library build is not going to work
very well
so you cure that plasmid
from that hit strain takes about a week
we decided to use a genome-wide knockout
library first since we had that on hand
so that could immediately go into your
library build which takes again about
three to four days
and then you could go into the screening
and
phenotyping and then genotyping those
hits so the second round took about one
and a half months
at the same time we were
manufacturing
uh well we designed and manufactured the
first round hits
library so we took all the 74 hits here
threw them into one library
and we built that first round hits
library
or manufactured the reagents for it so
then we went into the third round so we
took one of our second round hits we
cured the plasmid from that strain again
that takes about a week
built
the library three to four days
and then um this is the first round hits
library
and then
we phenotyped in genotype that
so the third round took about one and a
half months as well
so in the span of about six months time
we're able to identify a hit a top
strain that had four-fold improvement um
in cbh1 production so a significant
improvement now obviously this timeline
can change a little bit depending on you
know
your
your strategy that you used so seven
libraries um in a first round is a
fairly large number of libraries so you
could probably cut that down um to a
smaller number and decrease the amount
of time that's spent
in this first round
which would shorten this this total time
point this total timeline for the
project
okay so that's talking about time well
what about effort so fte time
so that's actually quite minimal
so designing these libraries takes
anywhere from a half an hour for various
simple libraries to a few hours for some
of the more complicated libraries
so
not a huge amount of investment in order
to design these libraries
so building the libraries are curing the
libraries this is really minimal effort
it's really you know a few hours per
week
in order to put the reagents on the
instrument press go or go through the
curing procedure
and then phenotyping or genotyping is
about
a quarter fte in order to do that work
so a lot of the
the the effort is actually spent
phenotyping um your libraries so
while you're able to go through these
iterative rounds of genome engineering
very rapidly it also doesn't quite
require a significant amount of
resources time resources or people
resources in order to do that
okay
so as far as conclusions
so the onyx platform is really a game
changer
for dgtl cycles so it allows you to
rapidly design and build genome-edited
libraries using significantly less
resources
and it truly democratizes genome editing
so i like to use myself as an example
when i when i talk about this because
prior to coming to inscripta i had never
designed a library
i had never
built a library but i had phenotyped a
library
but now with the onyx platform being
available i'm able to come up with an
idea or a concept that i want to test i
can go into designer software very
easily and rapidly design a library
testing that concept
once the reagents come in i can put
those into the instrument along with the
cells and press go
and then build that library and once
that tube of edited cells comes out i
can immediately go into phenotyping so i
can do all of that on my own i don't
have to no i have to have
very little skills as far as
bioinformatics or molecular biology
skills
so it really kind of revolutionized the
type of work or how i do my work
another important point is that
iterative genome engineering with the
onyx platform allows for rapid
development of proteins
um improved proteins
so you know the the gfp example as well
as strains uh with significantly uh
improved phenotypes so
um
you know the gf the cbh1 expression
phenotype
and that alterations this is for the
heterologous protein is that alterations
in diverse cellular processes um can
impact heterologous protein production
it was kind of kind of amazing to me
that we identified 69 you know different
hits throughout the genome that could
improve uh cbh1
production so it really suggests that
there's lots of different pathways and
lots of different genes that are
involved in heterologous protein
production lots of opportunities to
optimize your strain and improve the
production of your protein
and with that i'd really like to thank
you for your time in being able to talk
to you about the platform and some of
the applications that we've we've done
using the platform and i'd be happy to
answer any questions that you might have
thank you eric for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
can you estimate the metabolic burden in
heterologue production as a factor or
any other metric
yes uh very good question so that's not
actually something that we looked into
um in any level of detail i mean based
on the growth curves it appears that um
there definitely is some sort of burden
that's putting on the cells uh when you
produce a heterologous protein you know
based on the fact that the the cells
seem to grow
more slowly or to to less of a degree
overall
so there is some level of metabolic
burden but we didn't do any type of
analysis to try to estimate what that
burden is or to look into that more
fully at all
we had if you have some ideas about
trying to you know direct some of the
flux of the carbon towards say amino
acid production
but we we didn't really test out any of
those types of concepts um within the
this project that they were doing here
but very good question
thank you
next question
you said that the cbh1 gene was
optimized for expression in yeast why do
you think you were still able to
identify hits in the alternate codon
library
yeah so
um so that was actually a concept that i
wanted to test there was there's some
reports in the literature that if you
introduce
um
say rare codons at certain locations
within the gene you can actually improve
the expression of a heterologous protein
and the idea is that um
when you're producing a protein you may
not want the fastest translation rate
possible
because
very often um there are places within
the translation time where you may want
the ribosome to pause or to slow down to
allow for a subdomain to fold properly
so what was found in the literature is
that you can sort of over optimize or
overcode and optimize a gene so that you
get very rapid expression of that
protein
but you may not get the most amount of
active protein in the end and that some
of them might be you know aggregated or
insoluble or
basically not folded properly
so
it came out of that concept um but
instead of just making say
uh
rare codon introductions throughout the
gene i said hey this is very easy enough
to do using the linux platform to really
design a library where you can just do a
site saturation synonymous mutation
library so i went in and used designer
to very rapidly design that type of
library
so the reason i think that you can pull
out some of these hits
even though the genius code and optimize
is one because of the you know
translation rate that that could
impact the overall amount of
active protein you get at the end
another thing is that you know we may
not know all the rules of codon
optimization and it could be that
there are
things that we don't understand as far
as say mrna secondary structure that
could impact translation rates
and also um
i can imagine that the
pool of trnas might change during growth
conditions so maybe at the beginning of
growth you might have a different pool
versus you know mid-log phase versus the
end of growth and that what you think
you might be optimizing for you know
overall as far as protein production it
might vary at different stages of growth
so those are i think some of the ideas
uh that might explain why we're able to
pull out hits
in that codon
alternate codon library for cbh1
thank you
next question how flexible or robust the
designer software is when it comes to
non-canonical
non-model microbial species what are the
inputs and outputs of the software
yeah so the currently the platform
um is is optimized and really supports
um only using e coli um and srvca
so the the
software and the you know the design
scores and the the guide rna designs
that's all been optimized for use in e
coli and srvca a couple different
strains of each one of those
so it doesn't really support the use of
other microbes at this time this is
something that we're we're really
mindful of you know we get a lot of
input from people of hey are you going
to support
my species my strain of yeast or my
strain of bacteria so this is you know
input that we're taking
at inscripta and you know there are
things on the roadmap as far as you know
future uh species expansion
um but right now that the platform
really only supports the use of e coli
and necessary vca and the designer
software um it also only supports e coli
and s cerevisiae
thank you
next question
can you further describe the use of
barcodes are they incorporated into the
genome
yeah good question um so they're not
incorporated into the genome so they're
actually maintained on the plasmid so
there's a plasmid um that is used for
editing in yeast there's multiple
plasmids for e coli
um so they're actually not incorporated
into the genome um it's they're they're
maintained um on the plasmid
so
uh if you want to do sort of like a
selection type of experiment where you
grow say a population maybe there are
two of edited cells that come out of the
instrument under some sort of selective
um
pressure uh you can do that and then at
the end of your your selection
experiment you can just sequence the
population of cells that are
that are contained in that where you
know some edits might have caused an
enrichment in um certain strains whereas
other edits might have caused the
depletion
and you can basically just sequence the
barcode um and basically the barcode is
a proxy for the edit that's contained
within that cell and the number of that
barcode is sort of a proxy of the number
of cells within um that population that
contain that particular edit
so yes so the answer your question um
it's it's not integrated into the genome
it's maintained on the plasmid
thank you
next question if you have multiple
copies of the same expression cassette
in the genome well the edits designed
within the cassette actually been done
to all these copies
yes another good question um because
yeah for heterologous protein production
very often you have multiple copies of a
gene
so
the
to answer your question is um the
you will get editing at some number of
of the location so
you know biology says that you know you
put a guide in there um and you put um a
repair template you're going to get
cutting or potentially cutting at
multiple sites and you can get editing
at multiple sites
um but
it's not clear you know it you won't
necessarily get editing at all of them
um or you might get editing it none of
them depending on you know how good your
guide is and and how good the editing
actually takes place for the repair so i
will say that we've tested this out um
at you know multi-copy or
basically multiple locations where
there's multiple copies of the same gene
and sometimes we get editing at both
locations sometimes we'll get editing at
only one location sometimes you're
getting it none of the locations so you
can get
quite a mixture of cells at the end
i think for the most part we saw that we
got editing at multiple locations
when we tried this type of experiment
now that's with two two loci so you can
imagine as you increase the number of
locations four five six seven and eight
and if you're actually introducing cuts
at all of those different sites
simultaneously that can be very toxic to
the cells um and it's probably gonna
dramatically decrease your editing fish
efficiency and and frequency if you try
to um introduce
cuts at many many locations but you know
a handful of locations maybe it's going
to be okay
we definitely see that it becomes more
toxic to the cells at two sites three
sites definitely is much more toxic
so you kind of have to keep in mind the
number of locations that you're
targeting
currently the software actually only
supports editing at one location um but
it's something that we're we're planning
to enable um soon that will allow uh
editing at multiple locations so
basically multi-copy editing within the
same genome thank you next question
in the third generation strains what was
the amount of protein in grams per liter
in the shake flask tests
yeah that's a good question so i haven't
actually gone to measure the amount of
total protein that's being expressed
um it requires me to purify some of the
protein and then have a standard that i
can use um sort of to quantify the
amount i haven't done that experiment
yet but it's something that i definitely
want to do to kind of get an estimate of
the amount of protein that's being
produced
but that's i don't have an answer to
that question right now
thank you
next question do you think that with ale
the third round hits could be adapted to
grow at the same rate as wt
any thoughts around the cells adapting
to the onyx micro environment during
transformation and library screening
yeah so i think that's kind of two
questions so one of them is i guess can
we improve the growth
um of the cells um the you know these
third round strains
using uh an ale type of experiment and i
think that's definitely possible
that you know something like that could
could potentially work
um i think the other question is related
to what happens you know on the
instrument in in the micro environments
when editing takes place and um
yeah so definitely there's a lot of
biology that's happening on on the
instrument um
and
you know it's not clear exactly you know
there could be all kinds of things that
are happening and the cells are adapting
you know to those micro environments um
you know you're putting stress on them
um by
inducing editing you're inducing cutting
and then editing so there's definitely
some stress that that can be happening
to those cells
there's not a clear picture of you know
what exactly is happening on the
instrument in those micro environments
but but definitely it's it's it'll be a
somewhat of a stressful environment for
the cells
thank you
um next question
uh and it could possibly be a two-part
question so do you confirm the loss of
plasmids before phenotyping and if not
do you see any heterogeneity in its
phenotype
so the first question is do we confirm
the loss of the plasmid so in these
types of experiments that we're actually
doing we don't we actually maintain the
plasmid
um so i grow it under selection to to
maintain the plasmid you can definitely
do phenotyping um so that you you don't
maintain the plasmid and that you lose
the plasmid the plasmid is not required
in order to do your genotyping at the
end
um so but in the experiments that i
described here i actually did
grow those cells under selection to
maintain the plasmid
so and and i was able to you know
identify those hits
what happens when you remove the plasmid
i don't know at this point you maybe you
get greater expression of the protein
because definitely you know maintaining
that plasmid can put some
metabolic burden on the cells
and then
what was the second part of the question
the second part
was
uh if not do you see any heterogeneity
in its phenotype
ah
so
i
i think the question is do we see
heterogeneity within a sample um with
the phenotype and that we don't um it
seems like it's you know pretty stable
as far as what we're seeing uh
as far as the plasmid but if the
question is if we you know lose the
plasmid or remove the plasmid what
happens to protein expression that i
don't have an answer to at this point
because i haven't tested that
all right thank you
next question
could this tool be applied to other
yeast model organism
as
pipia
it pikia or pichia pikia pastor okay
yep yeah good question so um as i
mentioned so we're currently supporting
um
uh esther of eca as far as yeast we do
hear a lot of interest in in pikia so
that's probably one of the most common
um organisms that we hear that uh people
have interested in uh using you know on
the onyx platform so we're definitely
mindful of that and and thinking about
that as far as um you know future
expansion of the platform to to new
species so pikia is definitely one of
the the hot ones that we hear a lot of
interest in
but at this point it's it currently does
not support pikia
great thank you um it looks like we have
time for one more question
do you use
do you use
do you have to use whole genome
sequencing to find out which mutations
are changed in the libraries
so you don't have to do that so there's
actually
a few different genotyping techniques
you can you can use
so one of them is you could just if you
maintain the plasmid you could just read
the barcode you could sequence the
barcode sanger sequencing and figure out
you know which edit
that correlates with
if you want to look at the to make sure
that the edit is actually introduced
into genome
um you could do
uh
barcode sequencing to identify what's
the edit that's supposed to be in that
gene or even that in that
strain and then you could do sanger
sequencing of the genome so basically do
pcr amplification of the genome around
that location
and then do sanger sequencing
to identify the to confirm that the edit
is actually um
in the cell at the location that you
want or you could do whole genome
sequencing whole genome sequencing is
tends to be the most expensive way to do
it um but there's lots of different
strategies you can use uh to do your
genotyping and to confirm that the edit
is actually introduced into the genome
but a good question
great well thank you again eric for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor inscripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you